And of course what it all clarified was the fact that the Antifa
activists are, have a very clear policy,
which is that they want to provoke the police or need any law enforcement
into something they can pretend is an act of violence that they can catch on
camera and use as an explanation for the allegedly fascists nature of the
American state.
[Inaudible].
When you left Los Angeles, I said goodbye to you. And you said,
I'm going to Portland. And I said, why are you going to Portland?
And I think you said, I need to see it for myself. So you went up to Portland,
what'd you see up in Portland?
I slightly shot my bolt on this because I wrote a piece for one of the papers
saying California is a, California is a failed state. And then I went to Oregon.
Um, yeah. Um,
Portland is some people say to me, you know,
why do you need to go and see this stuff for yourself? And I just think it's,
it's an instinctive curiosity I have. And I also,
even when it is exactly what you think it is going to be,
it's still interesting. You know, um, Portland,
Oregon was exactly what I feared. It would be, but a bit worse. Um,
I was horrified by the immiseration of the city,
the total destruction of all public monuments and public buildings,
the shuffling up of shops, intimidation of the citizenry,
the demoralization of the citizenry, uh, a homelessness problem,
which makes even California's look minimal. Um, and, uh,
the fact that the city is basically been given over to, uh, an,
a misery to lawlessness.
I went with Antifa several nights in a row,
uh, to pardon the language, a gentrification protest,
which was my first. And, um, yeah,
it was, yes. I've heard the two always avoided the temptation. I,
I quite like gentrification, actually. I think it's, uh,
I think that how has this being made nicer and neighborhood being smarter is no
bad thing, but old fashioned view. Uh,
certainly not the view of anti for important who sectioned off some of the
streets and went through them in the middle of the night,
screaming at the citizens and the house owners telling them they will all stay
on stolen land. There's included many black families, by the way, uh,
shouting at these black families, white families, families,
wherever the background, shouting at them, they were on stolen land and, um,
and should get out.
Were you worried, were you worried for your own safety? I mean, you were,
you were out there with them. I mean, people know who you are.
Yes. I was. Um, uh, lucky enough in the era of mask wearing,
you can cover almost your entire face, uh, lawfully, indeed,
almost compulsively. And, um, uh, I was,
uh, I mean,
I've been worse places and war zones where there's more
lawlessness than that, but I, I, it was not an, a pleasant situation to be in,
in a, what is nominally, a first world city? Um, uh,
the second night I went with them to the protest,
to the ice facility where, um,
which was a bit Harrier because they were assaulting the,
so it is one of the very few, um, federal buildings in the, in the area.
Uh, they play a game of cat and mouse with law enforcement.
They get closer and closer to the front of the building.
Their aim in the past has been to barricade in the buildings,
put burning dumpster trucks in front of them,
and then kill the people inside by burning them alive.
So that's their modus operandi.
So you can understand why the ice officers don't want that.
And they get within a certain closeness to the door and then the,
uh, officers break out and, uh, there was firing tear, gas,
pepper, bullets, and all that.
And people were setting fire to things in the street. And, uh, and that was,
that was a unpleasant. Yes. Uh, it got, um, uh, uh,
uh, you know, shoot out of, uh, uh, of, uh,
an alleyway by federal officers with a bunch of other Antifa
with me. And, um, the officers at gunpoint, you know,
told us please to move out of the alleyway and it was
unpleasant, but I have to say that considering the situation,
I thought the officers, whereas as decent and reasonable and, uh, um,
efficient in their duties as they could possibly be.
And of course what it all clarified was the fact that the Antifa
activists are, have a very clear policy,
which is that they want to provoke the police or need any law enforcement
into something they can pretend is an act of violence that they can catch on
camera and use as an explanation for the allegedly fascists nature of the
American state. Um, they are,
it was very interesting to see these activists up close.
I thought they were all, um, reprehensible people.
I thought they were clearly mentally in a very
unstable place. I thought that furthermore,
on election night in Washington, DC, when I saw Antifa, um,
gathering in the doorways, just outside the North lawn of the white house,
the world's press were pointing their cameras at the white house.
And beside them underneath some of the doorways I saw what was clearly for
gathering because they were changing into clothes so that they couldn't be
recognized by if CCTV cameras, uh,
went over to film this because it was clear that this was what was going on.
And they became very violent, very fast. And, uh, um,
uh, they are thugs. They're a paramilitary group.
They have no place in a democracy. Um,
it's to America's shame that they've been allowed to do what they have been
doing. They threatened to kill journalists.
They had graffitied kill Andy mutual friend,
and a journalist and reporter in Portland, Oregon.
They had repeated calls to murder him across the city.
Um, uh, the fact that they can then intimidate a journalist, uh,
from abroad who even has the tenacity to try to capture them on
video camera, uh, or look at what they're doing is very bad.
There's an embarrassment from America.
I think the whole thing's an embarrassment.
Did you get a sense that when you're on the ground with him,
that there is a leader because you know,
this is what Joe Biden described Antifa as an idea.
And partly what I think it seems to be is that there's no sort of known leader
sort of by design, but when you're out there with these groups, DC, Portland,
wherever you are, could you sense like, Oh,
somebody is actually in charge or is it just like this roving gang? Yeah.
No, of course they have a leadership. Uh,
Andy knows forthcoming book will reveal a lot about this. Um, but yeah,
of course they have a leadership. Uh, they don't gather like, uh,
moisture or something. I mean, it's a, they are brought together.
They are organized, they advertise within their own groups,
what they're going to do and when, and what their actions are.
They tell people what to bring or what not to bring what to
say and what not to say, what to chant and what not to chant. And, uh, um,
and yeah, I mean, they, they, they, they do the whole thing.
They have an organized group. And by the way, one of the,
one of the most haunting things for me was, uh, I mean, I,
I interviewed lots of people on my travels, including black police officers in,
uh, Oregon, who I think were some of the most, um,
the bravest most remarkable. And I thought, um,
restrained people I've ever met. Uh,
but one of the concessions that haunted me even more than that was speaking to
an owner of a restaurant in caffeine, uh, Portland who, uh,
had just recently had, um, just the day before had had bullets live ammunition,
but it's fired through the windows of his, his business because he,
it seemed because he has photos on the wall of, um, first responders,
a woman, a woman soldier, a us soldier,
a man in Fireman's uniform. And this apparently makes him a,
a representative of the fascistic American state,
thus live ammunition is fired by Antifa BLM activists through his business.
By the way, he is a, is a black American, a very proud Patriot.
And he said to me, actually, we talked about this. I said to him, you know,
what do you think of the, uh, of the them presidential contender,
Joe Biden's claim that it's just an idea.
And he pointed to the bullet holes in his business, his windows, and he said,
but an idea, doesn't fire bullets.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.